when it comes to PC gaming the monitor
you choose matters a whole lot more than
people think sure you can buy any basic
1080p monitor for around $100 but a
gaming monitor is built for gaming with
gaming specific features so in this
video we're comparing four of the top
gaming monitors under $200 to see which
one you should buy for your gaming needs
and we'll have link to these monitors in
the video description below the first
one is a 24 inch curved monitor from
sceptre for a hundred and sixty three
dollars than the 24 inch Zowie monitor
from BenQ for $199 than the 24 inch Acer
nitro monitor for a hundred and sixty
dollars and finally a 27 inch monitor
from Dell for a hundred and eighty
dollars which we've already covered in a
previous video for being the
best-selling gaming monitor on Amazon
before we get into build quality and
design let's compare some specs the
resolutions the same across the board
with full HD 1080p and for panel tech
the Dell and Ben Q get a TN panel while
the sceptre gets VA and the Acer gets
IPs the difference is seen in a few
different things mainly including
response time viewing angles color
accuracy price and refresh rates for
viewing angles the Acer and it's IPS
panel easily beats out the rest and it's
the same thing for color accuracy as
well
however IPS panels are more costly to
produce especially with high refresh
rates and that's why the Acer only
refreshes at 75 Hertz compared to 144
Hertz on the rest of these panels the
144 Hertz model of the IPS monitor costs
a much higher 285 dollars in IPS panels
typically have slower response times but
with a sirs visual response boost mode
on it'll hit a one millisecond response
time but some users complain about
flickering issues and monitor brightness
going down with VRB mode enabled which
may be an issue since it's already rated
at only 250 nits of brightness with the
dell being rated up to 400 nits with a
sir's visual response boost disabled
response time goes up to 10 milliseconds
a lot slower than the rest
the Behnke monitor is the only monitor
out of the bunch that doesn't support
free sync a technology that helps get
rid of screen tearing and stuttering
when FPS doesn't match them on
refresh rate they all have a cements but
the scepter has a smaller 75 by 75
millimeter pattern so be aware of that
now let's compare the physical design of
the monitors from the front that Acer
looks the best with the thinnest bezels
overall and the best looking stand out
of the bunch
the BenQ has huge bezels all around in
an enlarged area for the controls not to
mention a massive and thick stand so
it's not the best choice for looks from
the side the scepter is very thin and
sleek compared to the rest and it's the
only one that's curved the BenQ and Acer
are by far the thickest from the side
due to the scepters low-profile stand
the display sits closer to the wall than
the rest of the monitors with Adel in
second place and been cues display
sitting the furthest from the wall so if
you have a small desk
the scepter ones here as for the stands
the scepters is the only one that's made
out of a solid piece of aluminum
compared to plastic stands with aluminum
plates and the scepter is by far the
sturdiest when you wiggle the desk with
a larger BenQ in dell wobbling the most
as for adjustability the BenQ destroys
the rest of the monitors would tilt side
to side swivel up and down height in
ninety degree rotation adjustability for
a vertical set up the rest of the
monitors literally only tilt forward and
backward the main drawback is the lack
of height adjustments since some of
these monitors sit pretty low as for
cable management the Dell and Acer have
basically none at all the sceptre comes
with a couple of plastic Clips that you
can adjust and they work very well and
the BenQ has a plastic clip on the back
which works great as well as for the
cables that come in the box
the sceptre is the only one that comes
with an external power brick the rest of
them have power supplies built into the
monitor however the sceptre does come
with the DisplayPort cable in same with
the BenQ monitor as well the Dell comes
with an HDMI 2.0 cable which isn't as
good as having DisplayPort since Nvidia
graphics cards require display ports as
a port AMD freesync now the Acer
actually came with an ancient VGA cable
which is so old that the budget rx 580
from 2017
doesn't support it so you will have to
buy an HDMI cable to reach 75 Hertz
since the monitor also doesn't support
DisplayPort now onto the i/o the Acer is
limited to two HDMI 1.4
a VGA port an audio import for using
your monitor speakers when you're using
VGA and a headphone jack the sceptre
comes with two clearly labeled HDMI
ports a display port also capable of 144
Hertz and a headphone jack the dell has
hdmi and displayport both capable of 144
Hertz a headphone jack in two USB 2.0
ports for peripherals the BenQ comes
with the DisplayPort and dual link DVI
port both capable of 144 Hertz and an
HDMI port which I believe is limited to
60 Hertz it also has a headphone jack on
the left side which may be more
comfortable to use and it's the only one
without built-in speakers which honestly
doesn't really matter now firing them up
let's compare the menu controls and UI
the Dell has clearly labeled controls on
the front that are very easy to use and
the UI is very simple and works
perfectly the sceptre has three buttons
on the back which you'll have to take a
look at to understand and it'll take
some time to get used to the UI is a bit
cluttered but it works ok overall the
Acer has a joystick that can be used to
change every setting and it works really
well along with three more buttons used
to quickly change things like input and
brightness the UI is simple and looks
better than Dells however when you turn
on one millisecond response time VRB
mode the screen dims like crazy and
freesync actually turns off so you can't
get both at the same time you'll be
stuck at a horrible 10 milliseconds
response time if you want free sync and
a brighter display onto the BenQ it has
an unnecessary bulge on the right side
for its unlabeled controls which don't
work very well because the UI was a pain
to use compared to the rest of the
monitors and finally we did some gaming
playing fortnight on each monitor to
test out how well each one performed the
sceptre played very well at 144 Hertz
using free sync and we didn't notice any
issues with gameplay except that the
display was a bit dim the dáil also
played great at 144 Hertz and there were
no issues and I loved how it was super
bright and the colors look pretty good
as well
the BenQ however seemed to play at 144
Hertz pretty well despite not having
free sync with great brightness and
decent colors too now the Acer was
another story it's limited to 75 Hertz
and since the 1 millisecond virtual
response boost mode dims the brightness
as flickering and
was freesync I turned it off and dealt
with ten millisecond response time so it
didn't feel that smooth compared to the
rest because of that and the fact that
it comes with the VGA cable the Acer is
out leaving the other three the BenQ was
in third place for having the huge
bezels being very bulky overall with bad
controls and the worst UI along with the
lack of free sync we did enjoy all the
adjustability and good brightness but
it's the most expensive at $199 the
sceptre just barely got into second
place by being priced at a hundred and
sixty dollars the 144 Hertz support with
either HDMI or display part was
excellent in the low profile design with
the sturdiest and helped outweigh the
negatives of the dimmer display and the
subpar menu controls and the winner is
the dell for quite a few reasons
you get 144 Hertz with either HDMI or
DisplayPort and it's the only one that
packs two USB ports you get free sync a
low two millisecond response time the
brightest display of all of these and
the largest at 27 inches with pretty
slim bezels as well the controls are
simple and intuitive and fortnight
played great at 144 Hertz the only
downsides are the slightly less sturdy
stand in the lack of cable management
other than that there's really no
compromises at a great price of a
hundred and eighty dollars and that's
why it's the winner if you want to learn
more about that display check out a
review of the dell after this video
we've left links of the best deals on
all these monitors in the description
below and if you enjoyed this video and
you've made your decision
use those links below to help support us
and click that button above to subscribe
this has been of a team with max TAC
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video